the Academy asked some of the world's
most prominent directors their views on
the current maturity of the toy that
became an instrument of art in Rome
Federico Fellini of eight and a half in
Stockholm Ingmar Bergman the Virgin
spring in Ireland the director of Doctor
Zhivago David Lean in Tokyo Akira
Kurosawa Seven Samurai in London John
Schlesinger nominated this year for
Midnight Cowboy in Rome sergei
bondarchuk war and peace and Franco
Zeffirelli Romeo and Juliet and in Los
Angeles Billy Wilder some like it hot
and Mike Nichols the Graduate we asked
them about censorship the new freedom of
the screen and where they're leading us
a lot of the people a lot of the studios
who make movies are racing after the
audience trying to find what will please
them trying to talk their language
trying to say what they think the
audience thinks without entirely knowing
what that is the taste of the audience
the I mean the development of the taste
of the audience I think that is very
encouraging and applies all of us to be
better to be more engaged to do don't be
so silly like in the past year it's a
difficult time in the industry at the
moment I mean there's a lot of changing
over that's happening and there are a
lot of very bright young people who want
to get into it and I think it's terribly
important for them that they fight with
all the energy they have and never ever
take no for an answer they are in a
position that didn't risk much so why
bother with obeying certain laws break
all the rules and see what happens after
that
not a certain degree of order a certain
amount of restraint is needed in society
with total freedom from any restraint
the world will become chaos I understand
freedom as a comprehension of necessity
we don't want to be free it's much more
easy to live with some protection to
live like kids with some board you say
to us what we have to do you can't
divide freedom which is important to all
of us you can't divide that freedom from
the freedom of expression and sexual
freedom they're all they're all one and
I'm I'm against any kind of thing well
I'd like to see total freedom from
censorship but I think it would be a
pretty rough five years because there's
gonna be all sorts of gentlemen who make
straight blue films at the end of five
years or something like that I should
think that people get bored with it and
everything is simmered down again I
think it's a risky business nobody I'm
not in your fake films nowadays are too
much concerned with sex
if nudity are candle elements can be
introduced in the movies for a creative
purpose I'm not against it at all well
let me see this I am against censorship
and I am for more nudity I just think
that what we should have is sort of
saturation bombing until be a good and
thick of it nudity leads us into the
arms of the
and vomer knew that I mean it has a
ninja with no today I think it has much
more to do with whether we're able to
breathe the air and we were able to have
our children and not worry and whether
we're not going to kill each other I
don't think it's very important whether
people are how they dressed or whether
they dressed and I think after we've
used up all the four-letter words there
will be a glorious resurgence
re-emergence of its realtor would would
be a film director except by directing a
film we asked our directors how they got
their start oh I started carrying teeth
the camera Department and in those days
there weren't any unions and I did
almost everything camera assistant
director at one month I was even
wardrobe mistress I was a newspaperman
in in Vienna in Berlin and then I
latched on to a group of young
filmmakers ruined an accident it really
was an accident I was going to be a
painter an artist I think I was about
six years old and I got a little just a
little cinematograph you know as we wish
I could sit and to see on the wall a
little picture you know and and I I
bought small films and that was the
beginning and I made some films when I
was a student and I became a
professional actor and from there I got
bored with just being an actor cuz I
wasn't good enough I have invented
something to tell you about that I am
very okay I acted as I worked and I
studied and I saved and then some
friends of mine got me a job Richard
Elizabeth Burton they recommended me for
my first picture and I got it so I got
my first job through connections